kit eco coaticook au concasseur de cacao
icco côté mis beaucoup qu'aucun le
concasseur de cacao a remarqué
caracolant caduque et cacochyme conquis
par les coquins kaka de kiki la coke
autocritique et la cocotte à croquer
karanka qui a connu quelques arguments
que le concasseur de cacao il s'aperçut
que kaki la conquête avait retenu marc
picard en collant caduc à cushing a
croqué karanka qui accole de cacao icco
conclut je crois mon côté je suis le
cocu passé dans le domaine scientifique
car cet homme qui a toujours trois
galets dans la bouche va tenter quand ce
ne sont que des galets les filles
potillon ces crèmes anti émeutes et les
prés de mes yeux attention vous étiez la
même vitesse n'a qu'à vitesse la sienne
à la sienne allez-y par une rumeur voit
vite et cocottes ecocup les cocottes
ekoko concasseur de cacao qui la cocotte
et m'aide beaucoup kokolo concasseur de
cacao au maquis cargo caucus